[Music]
central Edinburgh at 7:00 a.m. the no
rush it's the lost city look in a city
with a lot to lose 300 million pounds
for starters because this year the
summer festivals are canceled mark
Nelson cue comedy from the front room
it's gonna devastate the catering
community it's gonna devastate the hotel
industry and Edinburgh it's gonna
absolutely decimate the cocaine industry
and a lot of the UK as well The Stand
comedy club is among those improving a
live stream alternative showbiz survival
for artists without the world's biggest
arts festival is the most important
thing we have and yeah it's like our
Super Bowl once one vanishes you start
saying about the next one and then you
start writing the shul and then if it's
two months of previews to floor that so
it's kind of the culmination of a whole
yield what's or what so it's a big deal
for it not to be happening
[Music]
in Cromartie dr. Catherine Brown who
plays for patients musical therapy even
in two pairs of protective gloves this
Highlands GP has water underworld and
has known disaster by the Christchurch
earthquake in New Zealand what she saw
then is in keeping with what she sees
now it's mainly about people coming
together a time like this
within healthcare profession with a
healthcare profession and members of the
community rallying together to help out
in a real time of crisis your people in
Scotland have died from coronavirus than
previously thought
as her daily briefing because Thornton's
is a change in the way they feel like
this is touch words I hope as close to
situation to military being called to
services I might ever get to but because
we are on the frontline bond the
frontline in a medical sense can you see
and hear me ok I think it helps me
remind myself I am a human being and I
don't always have the answers and I
think to be honest certainly working in
general practice would you work with a
lot of uncertainty are you using zoom or
but this is this is learning to deal
with uncertainty on a different basis
all together you know and something that
like I said none of us have ever come
across before in this crisis of life and
death foodborne is less important but
it's life and death is an issue Mitra
Provost fan Rory so whether you still
connect with friends and also family
Margie I've got a self under weird there
are we and if we keep winning our key
we're not safe to March games and grill
that's all we people have some people to
come here that starts part the rumors
aren't as vulnerable as some but listen
to their Chairman's prognosis for
Scottish football without gave receipts
I would suspect that there's at least
half a dozen clubs that would be facing
going into receivership or
administration whatever you want to call
it in number three four five months time
and how you've Scottish football would
recover from I don't know
Rory's launched on donate a ticket
scheme were fans donate the price of a
ticket for a game they won't watch but
for teams they'll help survive some of
the best moments of my life will be
supporting Raith Rovers it's just a
massive part of your life and it would
be so honest I didn't realize how much
Saturday's main to me and now that
Saturday's just the same as every other
day Scott Schreiber goes deeper than
just Rangers and Celtic girls clubs like
Stenhousemuir and barrack rangers Queens
Park these guys have had massive massive
empaths enter the game in Scotland which
is you know a cornerstone of Scottish
culture back in Edinburgh I went to the
city's Marie Curie hospice where social
distancing has made its annual daffodil
appeal and possible they're seeking
emergency donations it's a financial hit
adding to emotional impact on a place
that treats people with terminal illness
families especially Angela McLaughlin's
husband and two daughters aren't able to
pay her a visit
coronavirus precautions forbidden 1014
and and it's been hard on name as they
have not been able to see me okay we're
doing FaceTime but it's not a same you
want a cuddle from here they made a
decision from day one to prevent the
experience of so many casualties of this
pandemic with precautions they time one
final family visit so that no one dies
alone if we can give that comfort to
families then that makes a difference
because conversely we know that if
people aren't there and can
see and therefore it's their imagination
then that's when they start being
tortured by it in weeks and months and
sometimes even years to come so this
really matters on life and death the
other rules rewritten James Matthews
skynews Edinborough